evening all right a great film critic
Roger Ebert once said that when a movie
characters really working when it's
they're really really working that we
the audience we become that character
now each of these five gifted actresses
didn't just make us feel for them they
made us feel like them broken gone lost
resilient determined and finally found
again here are the nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role
Mariano Kia two days one night Felicity
Jones the theory of everything Julianne
Moore still Alice
[Applause]
[Music]
Rosamund Pike Gonder reese witherspoon
wild
[Applause]
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Julian more still
out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I read an article that said that winning
an Oscar could lead to living 5 years
longer if that's true I'd really like to
thank the Academy because my husband is
younger than me there's no such thing as
Best Actress as is evidenced by the
performances of my fellow nominees I've
been honored to be among you every step
of the way I am grateful for this and
grateful for the opportunity to stand up
here and thank people that I love my
manager Evelyn O'Neal heaven humane
Steven Q vain Josh Lieberman my family
my grandparents my brother Peter
my sister Valerie my mother and father
who told me that I could be whatever I
wanted to be if I got an education
although I didn't think they meant being
an actress
I thank my dad for showing me the world
I want to thank everybody who made this
movie so many classics killer films
James Brown Lex Lucas Lisa Genova
Kristen Stewart Alec Baldwin I'm so
happy I'm thrilled actually that that we
were able to hopefully shine a light on
Alzheimer's disease so many people with
this disease feel isolated and
marginalized and one of the wonderful
things about movies it makes a seat feel
seen and not alone and people with
Alzheimer's deserve to be seen so that
we can find a cure and finally to our
film makers wash westmoreland and
Richard Glatzer who had hoped to be here
tonight but they can't because of
Richard's health when Richard was
diagnosed with ALS wash asked him what
he wanted to do did he want to travel
did he did he want to see the world he
said that he wanted to make movies and
that's what he did
and finally for my husband
Bart and our children Cal and live thank
you for my life thank you for giving me
a home thank you very much